opposition groups in Bangladesh have
called the Nationwide protests just days
after police cracked down on
anti-government demonstrations on
Saturday thousands of opposition
supporters rallied in Dhaka demanding
prime minister Sheikh hasina's
resignation ahead of next year's
election
well I'm joined live by Tanya trodhury
who's following developments in Dhaka
what is today's protest about tanvir
specifically
well it's part of a cities are
programmed opposition has been carrying
out since almost several weeks now but
today's program is mainly to protest
against what they say is a government
Crackdown on Saturday against a sit-in
program across the Dhaka city capital
the police heavily handed the opposition
and please
700 people were detained many leaders
were injured including senior leaders
were injured and beaten up by police so
the today's program is mainly to protest
that but it's also the main demand among
the 10 point demand one is the the
resignation of the government and to
form a administrative government under a
caretaker and neutral Administration so
that is one of the key demands today
despite all the obstacles tens of
thousands of people were able to gather
in the sarwardi Square which is in the
center of the capital you can't say it
from here we have to move because of
Internet disruption but already tens of
thousands of people are here a lot of
people are still coming in as the
Gathering is going on today
tanvir on the horizon is a general
election in Bangladesh and the
opposition hasn't yet decided whether
it's going to boycott the election or
run in the election they want a neutral
body to organize the election so that
they can be sure that this one is going
to be free and fair how is the
government reacting to all of that and
to all these recent protests
what the government is adamant it says
it won't step down nor will it have a
caretaker Administration it said the
election will be under its
Administration and it will be neutral
and free and they said the constituency
the Constitution doesn't permit a
caretaker government the opposition is
adamant that they won't participate in
this election because citing 2014 and
2018 election which was widely viewed as
rigged and fraudulent the government is
also under International prep pressure
from the U.S and Western allies as well
as the U.N to have a fair election that
came under criticism for rights
violation uh limited space for democracy
but despite all this the government is
adamant that it will carry on with the
election despite what the oppositions
say all right ten view ten year children
reporting live from Dhaka in Bangladesh
thank you very much